we'd go and do an event and you'd get
there and my brother would look at me
like what the hell are we doing here
it's raining on a Tuesday and we're
making pizza in a car parking space in
Hammer Smith or something this is
depressing and you do it and you'd be
like yeah this is depressing whatever
you do it and then you know you'd chat
to people there someone would give you a
card and then a year later you know you
even have that person back like great to
meet you like come and have a pizza
sometime and then a year later it's like
oh I'm actually like you know so and
so's best mate and I'm you know or I
know you know landlord who's got a sight
and he thinks you'd be great or just
these weird connections that just come
from like building those those actual
connections chatting to people and then
following up basically um and it's
happened to us over and over again and I
think that's the other thing I never
understand about sort of business as you
see on the Telly it's just this whole
like sort of aggressive you know I'll
step on your throat to get the next
level yeah it's like but that person
whose throat you stepped on is like an
opportunity that you've squashed that
will never ever come back to be an
opportunity